what's going on guys this is rob and in
the aftermath of spider-man no way home
this has left a lot of people asking
where are we going to stand with the new
spider-man movies how are those films
going to unfold right because we know
that sony and disney are working on a
new trilogy for tom holland spider-man
and one of the other things that had
come out recently really with an
interview that tom holland did with gq
is that if he was playing spider-man
after 30 he feels like he'd be doing
something wrong now he also cleared up
this interview more recently but the
overall gist of what he was saying by
virtue of the original interview and
what he said as an as a follow-up to it
is that in his mind he doesn't want to
play spider-man past 30 years old and
there's actually a couple different
reasons for this the first is because
he's got other career aspirations and
that's not unreasonable right in
hollywood there is such a thing as being
typecast a lot of you guys have heard of
this robert downey jr is a really good
example of that the guy's a phenomenal
actor but every time you see him you
will see him as tony stark despite
whatever movies he may make and how
popular they are mark hamill will always
be known as luke skywalker it's one of
those things that tom holland wants to
avoid he doesn't want to always be seen
as peter parker again we mentioned in a
previous video might be a little too
late for that but if he doesn't have any
major blockbusters or or huge franchises
that basically pick up steam between now
and the final film that he makes as
spider-man he'll basically be typecast
he'll always be viewed as spider-man and
so because of this our back is against
the wall to a degree in so far as what
they're gonna do with his character but
i think i know what's going to happen
with tom holland i think marvel studios
and sony are going to kill them off so
here's how i think things are going to
unfold right let's start with this first
movie let's kind of create a timeline
here right we say like 30 years old is
the cap well tomahawk is 25 years old
right now so if we go with the standard
fare and we say with all the projects
that marvel has going on we got like two
years before the next solo spider-man
film comes out which seems pretty
reasonable right enough time to plan the
film principal photography to start
shooting to basically do the editing and
then to release the movie and we know
they don't really shy against the idea
of releasing or at least finishing a
film at the 11th hour literally as far
as i'm aware spider-man wasn't done with
like editing
until about three weeks before the film
launched
their backs were against the wall so
much so that the rumors are saying they
didn't know or they thought they might
have to actually delay the release of
the film because they weren't quite done
yet but let's say it's like two years
before the new spider-man film comes out
let's say they rename the whole
franchise and just call it like friendly
neighborhood spider-man right that's the
next movie tom holland will be 27 years
old let's say that it's two years after
that when friendly neighborhood
spider-man 2 comes out now he's 29 you
guys get it he'll be 31 by the time the
last movie comes out so we'll say that's
it this this third movie they're doing
that's the last time you see tom holland
as spider-man in any capacity in the
marvel cinematic universe that means
that he's finished kaput done no more
peter parker in the mcu so i think the
first friendly neighborhood spider-man
we'll just kind of go with that title
we'll just kind of call it that let's
say the first friendly neighborhood
spider-man film that's going to show us
what peter parker's life is like at the
moment right it's going to show us
what's going on with peter parker what's
life like for him now that nobody
remembers who he is right no one knows
who peter parker is and so by virtue of
that nobody knows who spider-man is they
somebody just know that spider-man is a
guy out there but they don't know his
identity they're going to show us what
that life looks like are the characters
of mj and ned leeds still a part of the
equation does he check on them or are
they never going to be seen or heard
from again are the statements that ned
lee's made and saying like hey peter i'm
never going to become a villain and turn
against you or anything like that is
that something that that is kind of
foreshadowing right would he become the
hobgoblin i don't think so i think ned
leeds and mj are done right i think like
they're out of the picture if we see
them it'll be him checking up on them
and like that'll be the extent of it
right maybe he'll get his own love
interest maybe he won't i have no real
idea but the important thing here is
it's going to give us that kind of
scenario now the question has to be
asked who would the main villain of this
movie be and the answer is i don't
necessarily know right i mean when it
comes to the marvel cinematic universe
one of the things that we've learned
over the years is that villains come in
many forms sometimes they're as physical
and tangible as like thanos right like a
guy is coming to earth to steal the last
of the infinity stones and blink out
half the life in the universe and he
would have been defeated had it not been
for star-lord and thor good going guys
other times the villains are more
abstract they're not as physical i mean
i guess maybe kind of a physical nature
but like a giant celestial is emerging
from earth and will destroy the earth as
they emerge and so it's up to us the
eternals to stop them right it comes in
many different forms and so i wouldn't
be surprised if the villain you see in
this movie might be more circumstantial
than anything else i also wouldn't be
surprised if we saw peter parker taking
up some kind of gig at horizon labs
what's horizon labs this is a think tank
right literally the job of these guys is
to just sit around all day and think up
cool [ __ ] why does that matter because
we know horizon basically exists from
the morbius trailer and we know morbius
is in the mcu because of michael keaton
and so the thing about this is that
where it looked like the skyline from
morbius was basically the san francisco
skyline not going to swear to that i
don't recall exactly what it looks like
it may very well be new york that if
horizon is based out of san francisco
that maybe they have a new york branch
and peter parker basically works out of
that area we do know that we're probably
going to see peter parker taking
pictures of spider-man and sell them to
the daily bugle you can't not have that
that has to be in the movie
it's a cornerstone of peter parker it's
just part of what he does but i think
that's what the first movie is going to
look like it's kind of like here's what
life is like for peter right now but i
think at the end of the first movie the
piece of the venom symbiote that was
left behind in the marvel cinematic
universe and spider-man no way home is
going to bond itself to peter and in the
second movie peter parker is going to
become venom what i also think is going
to happen here is they're going to
introduce miles morales and so in the
second movie what it's actually going to
come down to is peter fighting miles
morales but it won't just be peter
parker it'll be venomized peter parker
and here's the reason why i think that
works right the venom symbiote in and of
itself bonding to peter just from what
we know when it comes to eddie brock it
has a kind of insatiable bloodlust right
it wants to kill it wants to destroy
things and i could certainly see peter
parker taking somewhat of a humorous
approach similar to the way that tom
hardy did in the venom movie but i could
also see him succumbing to it eventually
and the reason why is because if you
talk to anybody out there who knows
anything about the mental health
profession
keeping your feelings and and your
struggles contained that's how it pops
off and that's how people end up doing
incredibly violent things now let's look
at peter parker in the aftermath of
spider-man no way home no one knows who
peter parker is they've never heard of
him right it's like he never existed
he's basically starting over i mean sure
we'd have to assume information like
social security numbers and things like
that are still intact but he's getting
his ged so basically he never graduated
high school which kind of sucks because
everyone he met there right flash
thompson who was kind of a dick but also
lovable at the same time mj who we all
adored ned leeds who we all thought was
hilarious and the goofy teacher of peter
parker who was kind of an idiot but i'm
really gonna kind of miss that guy none
of those people know who peter parker is
none of those people have ever heard of
him so he's literally starting from
scratch the death of aunt may peter
parker remembers it all no one else does
but he does and unless he's talking to a
therapist or someone out there that he
is divulging his identity to he's
keeping all that inside and so it's not
that hard to believe if the venom
symbiote bonded itself to peter parker
and then drove him to give in to his
darker urges all that comes to the
surface and peter parker basically
becomes this vigilante that might even
take a few lives now i know the response
to that would be no no rob if peter
parker became a vigilante and killed
people
why would it come down to a fight
between him and miles like the avengers
would step in or something like that
would they though because in captain
america the winter soldier captain
america was a national fugitive hunted
by the world's biggest intelligence
agency
and outside of falcon
and black widow
no one showed up there was no hawkeye
tony stark didn't even call to see how
he was doing no one appeared and
spider-man no way home the movie that
just came out peter parker was an
international fugitive right hunted by
multiple countries for his perceived
crime of killing mysterio
in london england and you didn't hear
hide nor hair of sam wilson or winter
soldier or anyone like with the
exception of doctor strange and it was
only because he went to dr strange it
went like dr strange came to him and
said hey peter all right so i get the
things are popping off man you're in a
bad spot um i got this spell that can
basically fix things so let's go down
into my dingy ass basement and see if we
can't get this spell worked out or like
if the avengers called and said hey
peter i know things are popping off for
you we know you didn't kill mysterio so
come hang out at the avengers compound
in upstate new york where we probably
have panic rooms that will keep you
hidden away from everybody until things
kind of calm down and you can figure out
your next move no it was literally peter
just flying by the seat of his pants and
then going to doctor strange and then
screwing up a spell so it's not outside
the realm of possibility to believe that
if we get the origin story of miles
morales in spider-man 2 or even if we
don't right i mean literally spider-man
homecoming and spider-man far from home
and spider-man no way home was like a
three-part origin story for peter so
it's entirely possible miles could just
be introduced as this other guy
who has spider powers and like is the
only one who believes he can stop peter
who has a venom symbiote and the two of
them end up facing off now maybe it ends
up being that miles from his own
experiences and so on and so forth is
able to talk peter down because maybe by
that point miles mother is already dead
that was a huge plot point for the
character of miles the death of his mom
that was his uncle ben right totally
changed the way in which he saw himself
as spider-man and the fact that like
there's collateral damage when it comes
to him doing the kind of stuff that he
does kind of made him a little bit
darker for a little while but like being
able to bring that to the table and
saying like i lost someone close to me
too peter and kind of talking to him and
all that kind of stuff bringing peter
down it provides motivation it gives
significance to miles morales miles can
relate to peter his story is not that
different from peter miles has his own
struggles his own issues right the story
of miles is a pretty tragic one right he
comes from a really really poor part of
new york he attends a charter school
which for those of you guys who don't
live in the states a charter school is
essentially when your public school
system in your area is so shitty that
you attend a lottery system to try to
get into a better school right it's
pretty bad it's a pretty bad setup but
he goes to a charter school right his
story is pretty tragic it's pretty rough
but being able to bring all that stuff
to the table and then identify with
peter that way would give us as the
audience a reason to care about miles
morales more so than that you look at
him you're like man this guy is awesome
right so then from there you go into
spider-man 3. now the other part of this
with the second spider-man movie could
very well be that peter's actions as
venom lead to him doing something that
brings in eddie brock and eddie brock
hates him maybe it's following the
similar plot threats to spider-man 3
with topher grace and tobey maguire
whereas venom he exposes eddie brock and
cost him his career maybe it's something
more visceral where like he gets the
girlfriend of eddie brock killed because
he's not really caring about how his
actions affect people whatever the case
is there is a hatred that develops
between eddie brock and spider-man and
so at the end of that second movie by
way of miles peter casts off the venom
symbiote which bonds itself to eddie
brock but that goes into the third film
which is spider-man and miles morales
versus eddie brock or maybe it's just
spider-man versus eddie brock right like
peter's like no no this is my fight
right like this happened because of the
kind of things that i did i've been down
this road before i can solve my problems
i appreciate the help miles you do your
thing like you stay there you stay home
whatever it is i got this and i will
take care of it and ultimately over the
course of this movie peter parker is
killed by venom maybe that leads to
miles morales stepping in because he has
his venom loss right the electric shock
that he can send out as part of his
powers as a different version of
spider-man and he overcomes venom that
way but whatever it is it leads to the
death of peter parker tom holland is
effectively written out now i love the
idea that either peter parker and venom
fight to the death and they both end up
dying or miles morales kills venom where
peter parker could not and i know that
hardcore peter parker fans will say no
no that's ridiculous but like it's not
though and here's the reason why the
whole story behind miles morales was in
action right if you go back and you read
the ultimate comics when miles morales
originally appeared and then you get
like the events that led him to becoming
spider-man in the first place the way it
played out is that peter parker had been
beat to death right he was killed by the
sinister six really the final blow i
think was green goblin but basically he
was killed by the sinister six and that
miles morales seeing it all unfold could
have done something he could have you
could have like stepped in and helped
peter parker but he didn't but he didn't
he basically let peter parker die and so
you take that concept and you roll it
over into the mcu and it's basically a
repeat that yes peter told miles stay
away this is my fight i will deal with
it and yes miles could have ignored that
and he could have stepped in to help
peter and possibly saved his life but he
didn't that's important because that
gives motivation to miles it gives us a
reason for why miles is taking up the
mantle of spider-man in the first place
one part is because they're just
villains out there and new york needs a
protector and two because he wants to
honor the memory of peter parker he
wants to honor the memory of spider-man
by saying like yes i'm sorry i failed
you in the worst way but i will honor
your memory i will live up to everything
that you established as your role as
spider-man and i will i will treat it in
an honorable way going forward but
that's my thought on these three movies
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section right you guys
think that later i mean it's okay rob
but it's not gonna work or do you think
this is plausible because i really do
believe given all the little hints and
things like that that we've gotten so
far we're getting a miles morales film
but like a miles morales movie is coming
as far as i'm aware kevin feige's all
but said it right he's all but confirmed
it but like i would not be surprised if
they kill off tom holland and they bring
in miles as the new spider-man i really
hope they do i love miles morales god
he's such a great character i adore
miles he's like my favorite version of
spider-man but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace